the code of conduct needs to be reviewed
in every parliament and we need to make
sure that the rules that we have are
actually
enforceable
and of course what we've seen over the
last three weeks is the government sort
of deliberately trying to
make it impossible for a set of rules to
be enforced over paid lobbying in the
case of owen patterson um so i'm glad we
got over that moment but i'm slightly
worried now that what the government is
trying to do is sort of bounce everybody
into a set of proposals which have not
really been thought through very uh
properly my committee um is meeting next
tuesday we will consider all of these
matters and i and i hope that we'll be
able to produce a report very soon but
it won't just be on this one issue it'll
be on our suite of different issues that
we've been looking at for a whole year
and i think it's much better to look at
the whole code of uh conduct for mps
as one single unit rather than just
um some immediate reaction to a crisis
um which was created by the prime
minister himself as he said um driving
the car into a ditch on a clear day
uh the prime minister was being
questioned by uh chair
chairs of all sorts of committees within
the house of commons i'm trying to keep
it as as simple as possible for lay
people
so a lot of senior politicians were
questioning the prime minister yesterday
there's a better way of putting it you
spoke to him having spoken to him did
you get the impression that he had or
had not read the report into owen
patterson
i don't think he read the report at all
and and uh i'm not entirely sure that
his account of events
um was was very honourable because he
was effectively throwing jacob lee small
and the leader of the house of commons
and the
uh government chief with mark spencer
under a bus
um saying that it was all their fault he
thought that they were cross party
agreement look um if we're going to have
a new code of conduct it's got to be
done on the basis of cross-party
consensus because it's got to stand the
test of time
and it's all very easy for one side or
another to come up with with some a
great idea and but you have to go
through the details so
just as a for instance uh there is a
suggestion at the moment that um the
um that you should limit the number of
hours an mp can spend on uh
non-parliamentary duties
well i don't know what counts as a
non-parliamentary duty does that include
knocking doors in an election for
instance or not i don't know which side
of the
of the equation that falls um
what what do you say about traveling
between your constituency in london is
that part of your parliamentary duty or
or not and and more importantly how on
earth would the commissioner ever
investigate whether somebody had spent
more hours than they should or they
shouldn't on their parliamentary duties
of course every mp
should throw themselves heart and soul
into the business of being an mp and and
that's what all of us do i think i mean
um my day i don't want
you won't feel sorry for me i know
because you start very very early in the
morning but um my day yesterday started
at six in the morning and i finished
work around about five minutes to
midnight last night and that is not
uncommon for mvs um so the the whole
idea that
which i think dominic rob was espousing
there and and others were yesterday on
behalf of the government that it's going
to be very easy just to come up with
some plan in the next few days
which says um you can do so many hours
doing this and so many hours doing that
it's just
for the birds frankly
um starts at six o'clock in the morning
you've already missed an hour of the
early rundown by then i'm going to tell
neil patterson of you now let's talk
about owen patterson should we in a bit
more detail he broke the rules it has
been accepted by organizing a meeting
between the health minister and randox
doesn't seem to be any minutes available
for that meeting at the moment we're
told that there were meeting minutes but
they've now been lost and now we're
being told that potentially there
weren't any minutes at all
what are you going to do about that
well it's quite difficult to do anything
about an mp who is no longer an mp and
interestingly this particular part of
the owen patterson story was not part of
the investigation and that we did there
were 14 other meetings with other sets
of ministers and interest in
incidentally there was quite a lack of
understanding by government ministers as
to how the rules work on lobbying and
when an mp approaches them who's
approaching them on behalf of the paying
client and so we we may need to look at
that
it seems to me on the face of it
extraordinary that there would not be
minutes written notes of a formal
meeting between a government minister
about a contract
with a a with a member of parliament and
the company concerned and when the mp
and company concerned had a um
you know
a paying relationship that just seems
extraordinary to me it seems
um that's a matter surely for the
minister of code
how can you be a minister
and not keep minutes of such meetings do
the ministers not understand the rules
of the house of commons let alone the
probity rules in government
very good point let me
ask you this before i let you go uh from
today women will be working for nothing
to the end of the year because uh equal
pay is not as it should be it was in law
from 1975 as a result of what happened
in dagenham how can we still be in this
position
it's preposterous it's outrageous it
makes me angry every week um and
a lot of the changes that the government
has brought into taxation over the last
few years into benefits changes have hit
women worse than men one of the things i
would dearly love to introduce is free
child care universe free universal child
care for all regardless of wealth
because i think that would be the single
thing that would
release more women to be able to work it
would also incidentally i think improve
the quality of
child care in the country and on top of
that it will provide a a good career
path for a lot for a lot of people